[Musique]
je suis sûr que tout le monde connaît de
bons vieux remèdes de grand mère
le bicarbonate de soude pour blanchir
les dents le vinaigre blanc pour la
robinetterie et même comme utiliser ma
grand mère le bleu de méthylène pour
raviver la couleur des draps ou même
encore soigner des poissons de nos
aquariums toutes ces choses de notre
quotidien qu'on trouve dans nos salles
de bains dans nos cuisines et dont
l'efficacité n'est en fait pas à
démontrer je suis sûr que certains
d'entre vous ont des principes actifs
bien plus anciens qui leur viennent
spontanément à l'esprit acide ascorbique
plus connu sous le nom de vitamine c qui
accompagne pourtant tous nos hivers et
bien je suis venu vous confirmer que ces
vieilles molécules n'ont absolument rien
perdu de leur propriété et que nous
disposons en fait d'un véritable
patrimoine qui ne s'étiole pas au cours
des décennies donc la bonne nouvelle
c'est que pour faire de nouveaux
médicaments
nous pouvons utiliser ces vieilles
molécules et nous sommes pas à chaque
fois obligé de réinventer la poudre
alors vous l'avez peut être deviné que
je suis chimiste et plus précisément
docteur en chimie
mais je dois de suite vous faire une
confession j'ai aucune passion pour
chercher ce que j'aime avant tout c'est
trouver et ça correspond beaucoup plus à
mon tempérament personne aime chercher
quoi vous voyez tout le monde préfère
trouver si on dit bah j'ai cherché
champignons on préfère trouver des
champignons
et puis d'ailleurs je suis pas le seul
rappelez-vous le général de gaulle qui
disait des chercheurs qui cherchent on
en trouve mais des chercheurs qui
trouvent on en cherche alors c'est cette
culture de l'efficacité qui m'anime
en premier lieu et même pour ma thèse il
ya près de 25 ans c'est ce concept que
j'ai adopté je me suis immédiatement
focaliser à trouver des solutions aux
problèmes à trouver de nouvelles voix de
synthèse aux molécules et dans un
deuxième temps seulement attaché à les
expliquer scientifiquement
alors aujourd'hui comme je suis toujours
aussi passionné d'innovation
j'ai décidé d'en faire mon métier est de
transposer cette philosophie à la
découverte de nouveaux médicaments
mais avant que je vous en disent plus
sur mon métier
revenons un peu à cette idée de
développer et de greffe et du neuf sur
l'existant je vais prendre un exemple
qui parlera certainement à tout le monde
le palais de l'elysée savez vous que
cette année nous fêtons les 300 ans du
palais de l'elysée et oui 1718 donc
imaginez vous aussi à chaque nouvelle
élection
à chaque nouveau président nous
construisions nouveau palais je pense
que tout le monde conviendra que ça n'a
pas de sens mais de notre côté
y at il quelqu'un dans la salle qui se
contenterait d'être éclairée à la bougie
ou encore se passerait de l'eau courante
et je fais le pari d'ailleurs que peu
d'entre vous pour vos propres
appartements sont adeptes des toilettes
sèches
donc vous voyez que rester scotché dans
les standards du xviiie siècle
ça n'a pas de sens alors que s'est il
passé
c'est très simple le palais s'est
trouvée modernisé au fil des décennies
en incorporant les innovations qui ont
vu le jour et aujourd'hui ils gardent à
la fois toute la noblesse de son
histoire
mais s'est trouvée améliorée des
innovations qui ont vu le jour jusqu'au
21e siècle alors vous allez me dire rien
d'exceptionnel je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est très simple c'est ce n'est
que du bon sens et bien manger défendent
cette idée que le bon sens et la
simplicité sont une équation gagnante
jeu revitalise des molécules alors
revitaliser des molécules
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
donner une deuxième vie à de vieilles
molécules à des produits déjà existants
on développe ainsi de nouvelles
thérapeutiques qu'il n'avait pas être
explorées alors c'est fondamental parce
que ça nous permet d'aller beaucoup plus
vite de façon beaucoup moins risqué donc
beaucoup moins coûteuse
in fine et on est beaucoup plus efficace
pourquoi parce que des dizaines d'années
ont fourni des publications sur ces
molécules
alors pourquoi s'en priver tenez
reprenons un peu exemple du bleu de
méthylène dont je vous parlais tout
aveyron savez vous que cette molécule a
été synthétisé il ya plus de 140 ans je
suis sûr que chacun a joué avec au lycée
dans des éprouvettes que certains dans
leur enfance ont été soignés avec des
badigeons de bleu pour soigner les
angines où les aphtes d'autres même ont
utilisé des comprimés pour soigner des
infections urinaires 1 et bien cette
molécule
j'ai dû parier sur elle est en fait nous
avons repris son développement
pharmaceutique et bien sûr il était
inutile de repartir de zéro pour faire
entrer enregistré cette molécule comme
antidote auprès des autorités de santé
il nous a suffi entre guillemets de
refaire des études pour montrer le
rapport positif du bénéfice sur le
risque
et la faire reconnaître comme antidote
auprès des autorités
aujourd'hui ce produit est approuvé il
dispose d'une autorisation de mise sur
marché u 20 mm et sauve des vies dans le
monde entier alors vous voyez qu'on est
très loin du remède de grand-mère dont
je vous parlais au début mais qu'on
parle bien d'un antidote qui viennent
compléter l'arsenal thérapeutique des
médicaments d'urgence mis à disposition
des médecins du monde entier aujourd'hui
c'est cette culture de l'efficacité
cette dimension durable que j'entends
soutenir cette lutte contre le
gaspillage et cette valorisation au
bénéfice du plus grand nombre et en fait
j'ai la fierté aujourd'hui d'avoir notre
médicaments distribués dans les
principaux pays du monde et au meilleur
coût tu es au profit du plus grand
nombre alors à travers ce développement
durable ce développement durable et une
dimension de progrès un progrès au
bénéfice de tous et ce progrès ne se
limite pas bien évidemment à la seule
pharmacie et comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
cette façon de voir les choses cette
culture de l'efficacité est d'abord une
volonté de voir les choses différemment
une façon de concevoir l'efficacité qui
vit dans et avec son temps une réponse à
ceux dont on a besoin et pas à ce que
l'on s'invente parfois alors en
pharmacie comme dans tous les autres
domaines
nul besoin d'être prix nobel pour
innover je pense qu'un chemin et a créé
entre le statu quo et l'innovation de
rupture et en pharmacie comme d'ailleurs
dans tous les autres domaines
nul besoin d'être
docteur en chimie docteur en pharmacie
ou encore docteur en médecine en
revanche sachez le cette troisième voie
est réservée aux docteurs en bon sens
alors aux îles bon sens
réveillez le bon sens qui est en vous et
quel que soit votre métier quel que soit
votre domaine d'activité
à vous tous d'innover merci
[Applaudissements]